[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMIN IRANI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the new
episode of "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
Today we are going to see
that, as an organization goes
on an application
modernization journey,
and especially using cloud
native solutions, what
are the challenges
and the journey
that it has to
undertake, especially
if the organization has got
applications that have been
there for a while plus
combine that with the newer
applications and provide
this in a consistent fashion
via platform built on
containerization technologies.
I am Romin Irani.
I work as a developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
And today I am
pleased to welcome
Jeff Turnham, who's a principal
architect at HCL Software.
Welcome, Jeff, to the show.
JEFF TURNHAM: Thank you
very much for having me.
Yeah.
I'm Jeff Turnham.
I've been in
software development
now for just about 25 years.
The last four and 1/2 of
those have been with HCL.
I work on what's called
the platform team.
We work on crossplatform,
crossportfolio innovations.
And in particular, for
the last couple of years,
we've been really focused
in on containerization,
and Kubernetes, and our
cloud native journey.
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks, Jeff.
So let's get started.
And tell us a little bit more
about HCL and the SoFy product.
JEFF TURNHAM: Sure.
So HCL has a large
and growing catalog
of software we offer
software to our users
and business partners that
covers a wide range of areas,
things like DevOps
tools, security
tools, digital
solutions, customer
experience and marketing.
And we probably have a
lot of the same challenges
that other software
providers do.
And that is how do you deal with
all of the various platforms
that your users want to run on.
How do you handle licensing and
upgrades in a consistent way?
How do you do delivery of
software in a consistent way?
So we've been looking to
solve these challenges.
And a couple of
years ago, we started
to see that cloud native
technologies were starting
to provide a really nice answer
for a lot of those questions.
And so we used that opportunity
to take a fresh look.
And we've been on a cloud native
journey evolving our software
portfolio since then.
And I work on
what's called SoFy,
short for solution factory.
It's basically our
face to our users
and our business partners of
all of our cloud native efforts.
It's a catalog that
users can browse.
They can see all of our
cloud native software.
And the most exciting
part of it is perhaps
anything in the catalog, you
can click on, and deploy,
and try out in a few minutes.
And then you can
also take it away
to your cloud provider of
choice and install it there.
So yeah.
That's our focus.
And that's what we've been
working on for the last couple
of years.
ROMIN IRANI: That's interesting.
So if we could go a little
bit deeper and maybe
you could tell us
about how you went
about your journey and then
the role of GCP towards that.
JEFF TURNHAM: Right.
So getting started on
a cloud native journey
is challenging, especially
if you're, like we were,
starting from a position of not
being anywhere on that journey.
So we had to skill
up some teams.
We had to understand
the landscape of tools.
We had do lots of prototyping.
I personally did a
tremendous amount
of watching tech talks to
see how other companies that
are running their
business on Kubernetes
are doing these types of things.
And so once we got
over that hurdle,
we started looking across
Cloud vendors to see
how are we going to start
building some of these things.
What platforms are
we going to use?
And we pretty quickly
realized that GCP and GKE
offered a really nice balance of
usability versus full function.
And so all of our
development teams that get
started when they try out
GCP and, in particular, GKE,
the Kubernetes
parts, they get up
to speed very quickly, because
GKE makes it very easy to do
things in clusters, create
clusters, manage clusters,
and so on.
And then for our
operations teams
that actually run these
things in production,
they can get all
the capability they
need to go do observability, and
monitoring, and other things.
So for us, we actually did
try out several cloud vendors.
And we landed back on GCP and
GKE because of the ease of use
and because of the power.
One of the things we really find
appealing about GCP and GKE--
and this might
sound surprising--
is the documentation.
So most challenges we have
are just a search away.
We usually land
directly in the GCP doc.
And particularly for
my team, what we really
like is that everything that
is documented as actions
you can take in the UI
to implement something,
usually right there
beside it is documentation
on how you use G Cloud
or some other tool
to automate that
exact same thing.
And so for us trying to run
a fully deployed and robust
application in Kubernetes,
automation is key.
And so we really like the
fact that APIs, automation,
is built in from the ground
up in everything we do.
And then also I would also say--
and we weren't expecting this to
be as much of a deciding factor
as it is.
We really appreciate
the GCP support, so
opening support tickets.
And actually, most of our
support tickets are questions.
We'll ask questions.
How do we do this?
How do we do this particular
thing in Kubernetes?
What's the best practice?
And opening those types
of tickets is easy.
And getting responses
quickly is also easy.
So yeah.
Across the board, we're
very happy with GCP and GKE.
ROMIN IRANI: Thank you,
Jeff, for the feedback.
And it's good to see how our
existing online content helps
your team get up to speed
and also the documentation
and support along
with, of course,
the whole manageability of GKE
and out of the box monitoring.
So I think it's time now to go
to an interesting part, which
is to look at your
architecture and how
you brought this into reality.
So let's jump into
the architecture.
JEFF TURNHAM: Sure.
So just as a reminder, so SoFy,
short for solution factory,
provides to our end users
and business partners
a catalog of our software.
They can browse it.
They can learn about
everything in the catalog.
And then they can deploy it.
And they actually have
a couple of options
when it comes to deployment.
They can basically
take away a package
and go install it into their
own cloud native environment
or what we find gets the
most excitement is, anything
in our catalog, you can click
on and try out in a few minutes.
And the way that's
done is we actually
do a real Kubernetes
deploy when the user says
they want to deploy something.
So our architecture
works like this.
When our users first
come to our website,
they are hitting a
GCP load balancer.
That load balancer is
protected with Cloud Armor
so malicious traffic won't
even get to our application,
typically.
So when traffic does
get to our application,
then it's hitting what we
call the SoFy cluster, which
is where our SoFy
application runs,
the application that provides
the catalog and all of the web
experience that the users get.
So as users browse
around the catalog,
they're interacting with
our SoFy application.
And then when a user
wants to deploy something
quickly and try it
out in a few minutes,
they basically press
a deploy button.
And that kicks off
under the covers
a Helm install that
will go install
what they've selected out
to what we call our sandbox
cluster.
This cluster is a
very large cluster
that has all kinds of
various node pools in it.
We have Windows node pools
because some of our workloads
are Windows.
We have custom node pools for
some particular workloads that
need to run in a certain way.
And then we have the generic
Linux node pools and hundreds
of nodes.
And so when a user
installs, their application
gets installed in this cluster.
And they get back
network endpoints
that they can connect to a
few minutes later, typically.
So they'll be able to log
into our software, try it out,
and so on.
And across all of this
is all of the images
that are getting pulled.
All the container
images that are
getting pulled into
these environments
are getting pulled from Google's
container registry, GCR.
And for when we want to deliver
software to our end users,
we actually use another
image registry for that.
We're using Harbor, very popular
open source image registry.
And we run that in yet
another GKE cluster.
And then across all of
these environments-- and I
should say this environment
pictured here is
just one of our environments.
It's our production environment.
We obviously have internal
environments for our dev teams,
for test teams, for performance,
for security, for staging.
So we basically clones of
this throughout our work.
All of these environments
are protected
with various levels of security
but also observability,
and monitoring, and alerting
for when things go wrong.
And we also have
backup done with Valero
that backs up to Google storage.
And we can restore in
the case of emergency
very easily that way.
So yeah.
That's basically the
architecture in a nutshell.
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks, Jeff,
for taking us step by step
through the architecture.
And it's amazing to see that,
beneath all that complexity,
the experience that
you've given to the users
is a single click to
deploy the applications.
What I'd like to do,
as you are talking
through the architecture,
is specifically,
from a GKE perspective,
which forms really
the core of your
platform, could you
tell us specifically a
few things around GKE
and what particularly was well
suited to your applications?
Plus I'd like to touch a little
bit on the whole security
aspect with Cloud Armor and
how that service has also
helped you.
JEFF TURNHAM: Sure.
So yeah.
When I think about GKE,
the term that comes to mind
is progressive disclosure.
And I mean that in the
nicest possible way.
As a new user, when
you try out GKE,
creating your first cluster
is just a few clicks.
There's a whole bunch of
stuff beneath the surface
there for when you need it.
And so for us in particular,
our operations team
needs to understand at the most
detailed level possible what's
going on in our
clusters, whether that's
the SoFy cluster that
runs our application,
or the sandbox cluster that
runs all of the user deployed
applications, or whether that's
Harbor, our image registry.
And so what we really appreciate
is that observability,
and monitoring, and logging
is just built into everything.
We didn't have to do anything
special to enable it.
It's just there waiting for us
to run monitoring and logging
queries and get all that data.
So we built up an entire suite
around those capabilities
where we have alerts,
which will kick off
when certain events
happen, things like a node
going bad or pods going
unhealthy, things like that.
So we have all kinds of
stuff built around that.
And I'd say across--
to your security comment,
I'd say across the board,
our general experience is when
we need to use a GCP service,
it's quite straightforward.
So taking the example
of Cloud Armor.
I think it probably
took us an hour maybe
to install Cloud Armor for
our initial prototypes.
And most of that was
just reading the docs
to understand what it was doing.
The actual enablement of
it with the load balancer
and the appropriate
back end and our cluster
was really, really
straightforward.
And then we also had
to do some testing
to make sure malicious
payloads are getting
blocked and things like that.
But yeah.
The documentation, the defaults,
they were all set and tuned
very well for our use case.
And then when we do
need to make changes,
as we mentioned earlier,
it's all in the docs
and very easy to understand.
So I think that's
really why we like
using GCP so much is the
services are there when we need
them and the
capability is there,
even if it's behind a very
nice easy to use facade.
There's a whole bunch of
interesting stuff waiting
to be discovered.
ROMIN IRANI: The other
interesting thing
I'd like to ask is that,
as you built this platform,
I'm sure there were certain
points in time where you had
to make certain
architectural decisions
or certain challenges
that came your way to make
that platform a reality.
Could you throw some lights on
a few challenges that you faced
and sort of how you had to
overcome it as you went along?
JEFF TURNHAM: Sure.
So yeah.
Because we started
from ground zero,
I'm sure we've encountered
a lot of the same challenges
that any other organization
would encounter,
especially ones that are
starting from an existing
portfolio of software and
trying to modernize it or make
it cloud native.
So we've had to do quite a
lot of internal education
and enablement on these topics.
And one thing we
learned early on,
just to get specific, one
thing we learned early on
was that it's very
easy to skip over
some really important
parts of configuration
when you're deploying
Kubernetes applications.
So one example.
Anyone who's deployed
Kubernetes apps in production
will probably understand
this quite well.
But when you deploy a workload,
something that's got a pod,
the way you set its resource
limits, basically how much CPU
and memory it can use,
can have a dramatic impact
on performance.
And it's just two
little lines usually
or four little lines in YAML.
But it can have a
tremendous impact
on how your application
actually runs and performs.
And we saw this.
So we had some of our
existing software that
got put into a cloud
native form factor,
containerized, packaged.
It all looked good
but, when we ran it,
it was actually underperforming.
It was actually performing
much more slowly
than it would if you deployed
onto a VM or elsewhere.
When we looked into it, the
root cause was CPU throttling.
And so the interesting
part of that
is the fix for that is
usually very simple.
It's tweaking those
few lines of YAML.
But the trick is
knowing what values
to put in in the first place.
How do I know how much CPU
my workload should request?
How do I know what its
limit's going to be?
And so we, again, opened up
a support ticket with GCP
to basically ask that question.
How do we set these values?
What's the best
practice for doing this?
The support folks hooked us
up with some Google experts.
We got on a call, had a
chat about this topic.
And they basically turned us
on to the power of vertical pod
autoscaler which, when you run
that tool in recommendation
mode, it effectively answers
the question for you.
It tells you here's what
your CPU settings should be.
Here's what your memory
settings should be.
It's basically watching
your application
and giving your recommendations.
So we've rolled that
out across the org
and we're now focused on making
sure that, as our products
change, that we keep
up to date with that.
So we don't want
a product change
to introduce something
that requires
more CPU and our
configuration doesn't change.
So the question is,
how do you monitor?
How do you make sure
that you're continuously
checking and approving that?
So one thing that we're looking
at for the upcoming year
is, if you think back
to our architecture,
every time a user
deploys something
to what we call our
sandbox, it deploys
to one big cluster, that big
sandbox cluster I mentioned.
And that's got us-- it's
got us a lot of benefits.
And it's got us a long way.
The one nice thing about
it is it's one cluster
for our ops team to manage,
and maintain, and monitor.
And so when something goes
wrong, it's very easy to know,
oh, there's the cluster that
we need to go fix and so on.
However, there
are some use cases
that we really want to enable
for our end users and business
partners that we can't really
do or we can't do it robustly
with this current architecture.
One of them is, in
addition to just letting
users have access
to their endpoints,
the product endpoints
that they can connect to
in the deployed
application, we actually
want some of our users to
be able to get Kube admin
rights to be able to
use Kube control to get
into their cluster and
start poking around
and do things like check
on the status of pods,
maybe delete some pods,
change configuration, things
like that.
That's not something we'd
been willing to entertain
with a large cluster, a
large shared cluster, because
of the security implications
and all of the testing that
would be required.
So what we're looking
at is moving to a model
where, when a user
says they want
to try out some of our
software, we don't just
deploy their application.
We actually spin up
dynamically a cluster purpose
built for that workload.
So it would be sized correctly.
It would have the right
sort of node pools--
If it's a Windows workload or
it has some Windows in there,
it would have a
Windows node pool.
If not, it wouldn't--
and basically spin these
things up quickly on demand.
And so we want to move to
that sort of architecture
or at least experiment
and make sure
that that makes sense
and basically get
to a model of much more
dynamic, much more provisioned
infrastructure coming
and going quickly.
We also want to take
a much closer look
at GKE Autopilot, which lets
teams like us abstract away
even further from the concept
of nodes and really just focus
on our pods and workloads.
And so we'll be experimenting
with that as well.
So yeah.
Many other examples.
But across the board, we're
always looking for ways
to improve our architecture.
ROMIN IRANI: So the final
thing I wanted to ask you,
and I'm just curious
about this, is
that for a platform
of this type,
there are different stakeholders
in the organization.
So could you throw some light on
what it means to be successful
or how do you measure success
for a platform like this?
ROMIN IRANI: Great question.
And this is something
we've been building up
over time over the
last four years
that we've been working on this.
And so the way we see it,
observability and improvement
happens at various
different levels.
So down at the
technical level, which
we've been talking about up
till now, for that you obviously
need observability,
logging, monitoring.
You need someone looking at
those alerts, and those logs,
and taking action.
So that's almost the easy part,
because a lot of that logging
and monitoring
functionality is built in.
What's a little more
challenging, especially
for large organizations
with thousands of developers
and dozens and dozens
of software products,
is how do you move your
whole organization to become
cloud native, both in culture
and how they deliver things?
And so what we've
had to do in HCL
is not just hope and pray
that it happens organically.
We actually, at the
executive level,
have tracking of what we call
our cloud native maturities.
We have a cloud native maturity
model that we've built up.
It's built on a lot
of the best practices
that you'd go out and find other
people talking about with cloud
native, but it's
basically a scorecard.
And it talks about
things like how
do you build your
containers, both
for security but
also for robustness,
and logging, and
things like that.
How do you package your
containers into a Kubernetes
application effectively?
How do you ensure that the
application's monitorable?
How do you ensure resilience
and things like that?
So all of our products actually
get scored on that cloud
native maturity model.
And where there's
deficiencies or gaps,
that becomes part of
the product's roadmap.
And so this, as I said, is
tracked at the executive level.
It's not left as something
that each product
manager needs to make sure
they carve out time for.
And so I think, in a
large organization,
that's really the way
it has to be done,
if your end goal is
a consistent, cloud
native evolution across
all of your products.
I will mention one other thing,
just because it's top of mind.
We're actually doing
this right now.
We're really looking now
at a level of testing
that we've never done before.
I know other organizations
are far ahead of us on this,
but we're really looking at
chaos engineering as a way
to make sure that
our applications are
resilient against all kinds of
things that can and do go wrong
in production.
So we are now setting up full
chaos engineering environments
where we can run
all of our products.
We can inject-- we're actually
using litmus chaos, open source
project for this where we
inject all kinds of bad things
into our cluster, things like
network slowdowns, CPU memory
throttling, nodes going
bad, pods getting restarted,
all kinds of this
types of chaos,
and making sure our products
can handle it, and recover,
and, in the best case, have
no impact to user experience
during these events.
Yeah.
It's a constant journey.
And if you ask me four
or five years from now,
I'm sure we'll still
be on this journey.
And we'll be thinking about
new things and new ways
to optimize and improve.
So it's never ending.
ROMIN IRANI: So thank you once
again for sharing your journey
as well as giving us an
overview of how you built out
SoFy and particularly the whole
journey towards cloud native
and ensuring that,
along with GCP,
you are able to build
out this platform.
Thanks for sharing all
your inputs along the way.
It was a pleasure to
have you on the show.
Thank you so much, Jeff.
JEFF TURNHAM: Yes.
Thanks.
Thanks so much for having me.
ROMIN IRANI: Thank
you for joining us
for this episode
of "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
If you've enjoyed
this episode, please
like and subscribe
to this channel.
Thank you for joining us today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]